at what moment did you say that you were
really going to do this because we all
like think of these awesome ideas and
then they last maybe like what them a
day a week a month whatever and that's
essentially to what the book is about is
actually doing something not just
talking time okay
one of my favorite quotes is between
concept and execution there is a land of
shadow let's guess yeah I forget who
said it there's another one that I love
which is when all is said and done
there's generally a lot more said than
done
they're very true wholesome good and
maybe different in the Seattle area than
it is in LA but yeah la is known for
that so when did I really gear into this
I think it was it was sort of in that
moment or in that time period when I
realized that that this was really
coming from a deep place within me that
both the creative side was coming out
and the empowerment and inspirational
side and these things came together in
the book and you know the book is one
thing and you know we're getting that
out and whatever people are digging it
but I'm also doing lots of workshops and
this for me is actually more powerful
because you know I already wrote the
book and hopefully people read it and
that's great but interacting with groups
of people whether online or you know in
live situations really gives me a chance
to connect and you know obviously
there's a bit more to it than reading a
book like this there's humans at all so
yeah well the book the book has a lot of
humor in it and I enjoy the drawings as
well and you have one that's fairly
close to the beginning of the book where
there's a guy sitting on his couch
watching TV kind of slumped and
depressed with like maybe a beer by them
and and I find interesting because that
is the acceptable form of recreation
right and we've all probably fallen prey
to it and it's easy to go there why do
you think so many people reach for not
just a beer or whatever we will have to
talk about addiction or anything but
that safe place on the couch why is that
so commonplace because
seesee great I mean it's easy to lay
there and watch TV and click around and
drink a beer eat your ice cream or
whatever you're into it takes energy to
do things to do anything okay you know
whether you're going to write your book
or make your film or writing a song or
you know any of any of those creative
things take energy but here's here's the
difference at the end of the day when
when you're done watching your TV show
okay fine
maybe it was good maybe it sucked but
that's the end of it when you create
something that energy comes back to you
it doesn't come back to you with the TV
show generally right so the more energy
you put in the more energy you have
right if it's something that you
actually genuinely love now you talked
about this in the book and forgive me if
I'm getting too personal with it but you
said that during the time when you were
going to go to high school or leaving
high school to go to college that you
had a lot of people around you that you
were close to pass away yes and I'm
wondering did that was that part of that
sort of NFA mindset that you adopted
because you saw that people probably had
best intentions and plans and it was
definitely a very tough time for me you
know coming out of high school and and
you know the world is in front of us
right and all that kind of thing and
then suddenly seeing that like wow this
thing can and and has first you know
several of my friends it was it was a
huge shock and a deep it introspection
so just know that the time is always
ticking we don't know if we're going to
get another 50 years or another 10
minutes but there is always a limit to
this life as far as we know so what are
you gonna do with it and for me that
you're right that was a time when I was
so after I got out of that funk I was
like okay let's do something meaningful
with life because it is a gift and it's
something do you remember what got you
out of the funk it might have been
meeting the greatest guitar player I
have ever played with this guy called
Mike Schmidt in college I met this guy
and you know lots of people play guitar
and I played music with a lot of people
back then and and now but Mike was an
extraordinary musician like like ultra
level and for some reason he he wanted
to play with me
and in a band and he taught me a whole
lot not just about music but about life
through music so the story that I
remember that was really so be so huge
for me was at that time I would learn a
song and play it right to cover song or
write a song but I went to get together
with Mike I'm like okay Mike what song
do you want to play he's like I want to
play a song what you want to do he's
like just play just play I'm like and I
start playing the bass and Mike starts
carving music out of my semi chaotic
erratic bassline and it was beautiful
and what I got out of that was how music
can be open and free which is similar to
life right if the more structured you
are you know there's great stuff in that
but if you if you can be free and loose
with your plan magic can happen it's
like a Grateful Dead song you're at you
into the debt go into the dead well I
grew up in a town that worship the dead
I grew up in Palo Alto so yeah every
year a dead festival especially Hey so
it's dead sort of Jam every night right
I used to and some nights it was just
disaster was a sonic Messick you just
never like what the hell and then other
nights it was music that was just so
heavenly and divine and like how can
humans make something so beautiful
frying right but they have to step into
that chaos and they have to step into
that possibility and just see how it
goes
so that's kind of what I got from from
Mike back then
you